you and the world lost Jeff backck a
year ago you told me you really miss
him how's the pain of losing Jeff change
you maybe deepen your sense of the
world you know it's hard to accept that
we won't create
something musically again in this
lifetime
um but in terms of the
grief grief was easier for me because I
went through a major grief period in
2016 uh and
17 and that was the first time I'd
really gone through the process of grief
uh in a in a like in a non family
situation like with friends and mentors
and people that I'd created with which
which is different it's a different kind
of connection um when my grandparents
died it's like there was nothing left
unsaid and I was at peace with what was
happening with this when Prince died out
of the blue um in mid uh 2016 and then
Leonard Cohen died in
November that just tore me to shreds
because Leonard Cohen was was not just
someone that profoundly inspired me you
know musically and lyrically but
spiritually we had a very deep
connection um and that was the basis of
a lot of our conversation was
spirituality and so at that time I felt
like a piece of me went
missing and that was a very long process
where I just stayed in my
place and didn't want to play a note of
music I kind of wanted to just get rid
of all my stuff so I I had a friend come
over and he's like you should just why
don't you come to The Comedy Store I'm
like Comedy Store like what am I going
to go go to some store and buy clown
suits like what are you talking about
what's a comedy store he's like no no no
like The Comedy Store the place where
like comedians go I'm like okay well
I've I've never seen standup I
you know I've seen Seinfeld on TV that's
like the extent of my standup experience
so he took me to the comedy
store and every single one of those
comedians like embraced me like I was
family it didn't even take a day I was
like part of the family and I made like
25 best
friends and I ended up throwing all my
stuff in storage and like finding a
little room to stay in where I rented my
gear out um and that was me pay my rent
paying was me L loaning the gear cuz I
didn't want any any responsibilities
Financial I just wanted to be
completely free so that I could like
just process it and not feel like I had
to commit to anything workwise or
creatively I just wanted to unplug and
so this was like a fun and very
different way to unplug because you know
previously I may have just gone to a
monastery and spent you know weeks in a
monastery or months but in this case I
was like you know what this is a
different kind of experience I'm going
to just hang out with Comedians and stay
in this room and with no responsibility
really yeah other than to really deeply
connect with this grief that I'm
experiencing I'm not going to negate it
I'm not I'm I'm going to really
fully connect to it and I did and it was
tough and then you know more people in
2017 were leaving Greg Alman Tom Petty I
mean it was like these are people that I
I worked with all these people and like
had great connections with them and they
were all going and the world was
mourning the loss of these people
because the of everything that they'
they'd given to the world like they'd
changed the world's lives not just mine
cuz I knew him personally and so that
was also complicated and why
for me it was it was interesting to be
grieving the loss of these musicians
with comedians MH and uh I learned a lot
it changed my life because I just
learned to I learned to laugh at
absolutely anything everything I mean my
grandpa had a really great sense of
humor too my grandpa's a holocaust
Survivor and like he could just kind of
like laugh at anything and like so I
already kind of have that in me but
being around all these comedians just
kind of like exagger at that for me and
that really changed things for me for
the better so then when Jeff Beck died
it was like okay I've got these tools I
know what this is and and I'm going to
go through it again and I'm going to be
on tour with Incubus in two days yeah
and so Mike D from Green Day he called
me up he said hey like I know you're
going through a lot and I said yeah I
don't even know what I'm going to play
like I really want a vintage J has base
for this and I only have a 70s one that
I don't really think is appropriate I
really need a 60s one blah blah blah and
Mike's like I'm going to hook you up he
showed up to my place the next day with
a truckload of old PAB bases and Jazz
bases and brought them all into my
studio and I'm playing them and then I
pull one out of the case and it's it's
Olympic White just like Jeff Beck
and I play it and not only did I get
goosebumps and started crying but I
looked over at Mike and same thing was
happening and he's like uh I guess I
guess Jeff might might be happy about
this and he's like well you know I
didn't want to let this one go I was
just trying to cheer you up a bit and
maybe loan it to you for the tour but if
you really want
it it's yours and I was like oh my God
this is like like what a like Mike D is
the nicest guy ever um so so that
happened so that bass's name is Jeff and
it's a white Jazz base and I played it
on the incubus tour but yeah I do feel
like I'm more equipped to handle grief
now